today i want to
talk to you about swimming across the
north pole across the most northern
place in the whole world
and perhaps the best place to start is
with my late father
he was a great storyteller he could tell
a story about an event
and so you felt you're absolutely there
at the moment
and one of the stories he told me so
often when i was a young boy
was of the first british atomic bomb
test
he had been there and watched should go
off
and he said that the explosion was so
loud and the light was so intense
that he actually had to put his hands in
front of his face to protect his eyes
and he said that he could actually see
an
x-ray of his fingers because the light
was so bright
and i know that watching that atomic
bomb going off
had a very very big impact on my late
father
every holiday i had as a young boy was
in a national park
what he was trying to do with me was to
inspire me to protect the world
and show me just how fragile the world
is
he also told me about the great
explorers he loved history
he would tell me about captain scott
walking all the way to the south pole
and sir edmund hillary climbing up mount
everest and so ever since i think i was
just six years old
i dreamt of going to the polar regions i
really really
wanted to go to the arctic there was
something about that place
which drew me to that and well
sometimes it takes a long time for a
dream to come true
but seven years ago i went to the arctic
for the first time
and it was so beautiful that i've been
back there ever since for the last seven
years
i love the place but i have seen that
place change
beyond all description just in that
short period of time
i have seen polar bears walking across
very very thin
ice in search of food i have swum in
front of glaciers
which have retreated so much and i have
also
every year seen less and less sea ice
and i wanted the world to know what was
happening up there
in the two years before my swim 23
of the arctic sea ice cover just melted
away
and i wanted to really shake the lapels
of world leaders
to get them to understand what is
happening
so i decided to do this symbolic swim at
the top of the world
in a place which should be frozen over
but which now is rapidly unfreezing
and the message was very clear climate
change is for real
and we need to do something about it and
we need to do something about it right
now
well swimming across the north pole it's
not an
it's not an ordinary thing to do i mean
just to put it in perspective
27 degrees is a temperature of a normal
indoor swimming pool
this morning the temperature the english
channel was 18 degrees
the passengers who fell off the titanic
fell into water of just
five degrees centigrade fresh water
freezes at zero
and the water at the north pole is minus
1.7
it's freezing
i'm sorry but there's no other way to
describe it
and so i had to assemble
an incredible team around me to help me
with this task
uh i i i assembled this team of 29
people
from 10 nations some people think that
swimming is a very solo sport you just
dive into the sea and off you go
it couldn't be further from the truth
for me
and i then went and did a huge amount of
training swimming in icy water
backwards and forwards but the most
important thing was to train my mind to
prepare myself over what was going to
happen
and i had to visualize the swim i had to
see it from the beginning
all the way to the end i had to taste
the salt water in my mouth
i had to see my coach screaming for me
come on lewis come on come on go go go
don't slow down
and so i literally swam across the north
pole
hundreds and hundreds of times in my
mind
and then after a year of training i felt
ready i felt confident that i could
actually
do the swim so myself and the five
members of the team we hitched a ride on
an icebreaker which was going to the
north pole
and on day four we decided to just do a
quick
five-minute test swim i had never swum
in water of minus 1.7 degrees before
because it's just impossible to train in
those type of conditions
so we stopped the ship as you do we all
got down onto the ice
and i then got into my swimming costume
and i dived into the sea
i have never in my life felt anything
like that moment i could barely breathe
i was
gasping for air i was hyperventilating
so much
and within seconds my hands were numb
and it was
the paradox is that you're in freezing
cold water but actually you're on fire
i swam as hard as i could for five
minutes i remember
just trying to get out of the water i
climbed out of the ice
and i remember taking the goggles off my
face and looking down at my hands
in sheer shock because my fingers
had swollen so much that they were like
sausages
and they were swollen so much i couldn't
even close them
what had happened is that we are made
partially of water
and when water freezes it expands and so
what had actually happened is that the
cells in my fingers had frozen
and expanded and they had burst and i
was in so much agony
i immediately got rushed onto the ship
and into a hot shower and i remember
standing underneath the hot shower
and trying to defrost my fingers
and i thought in two days time i was
going to do
this swim across the north pole i was
going to try and do a 20
minute swim for one kilometer across the
north pole
and this dream which i had had ever
since i was a young boy
with my father was just going out the
window
there is no possibility that this was
going to happen
and i remember then getting out of the
shower and realizing i couldn't even
feel my hands and for a swimmer you need
to feel your hands
because you need to be able to grab the
water and pull it through with you
the next morning i woke up and i was in
i was in such a state of depression
and all i could think about was sereno
fines
for those of you who don't know him is a
great british explorer
a number of years ago he tried to ski
all the way to the north pole
he accidentally fell through the ice
into the sea
and after just three minutes in that
water after just three minutes in that
water
he was able to get himself out and his
hands were so badly frostbitten
that he had to return to england he went
to the local hospital and there they
said
ran that there is no possibility of us
being able to save these fingers we are
going to actually have to take them off
and ran rand decided to go into his tool
shed
and take out a saw and do it himself
and all i could think of was right if
that happened to ran after three minutes
and i can't feel my hands after five
minutes what on earth is going to happen
if i try 20 minutes at the very best
i'm going to end up losing some fingers
and at worst
i didn't even want to think about it
we carried on sailing through the ice
packs towards the north pole
and my close friend david he saw the way
i was thinking and he came up to me and
he said louis
i've known you since you were 18 years
old
i've known you and i know louis
deep down right deep down here that you
are going to make the swim
i so believe in you lewis i've seen the
way you've been training
and i realized the reason why you're
going to do this this is such an
important swim
we stand at a very very important moment
in this history
and you're going to make a symbolic swim
here to try and shake the lapels of
world leaders
lewis had the courage to go in there
because we are going to look after you
every moment of it and i just i got so
much confidence from him
saying that because he knew me so well
so we carried on sailing and we arrived
at the north pole and
we stopped the ship and it was just as
the scientists had predicted there were
open patches of sea everywhere
and i went down into my cabin and i put
on my swimming costume
and then the doctor strapped on a chest
monitor which measures my core body
temperature
and my heart rate and then we walked out
onto the ice
and i remember looking into the ice
and there were big chunks of white ice
in there and the water
was completely black i have never seen
black water before and it is four
thousand
two hundred meters deep and i said to
myself lewis don't look left don't look
right
just scuttle forward and and go for it
and so i now want to show you a short
video of what happened there on the ice
we're just sailing out of harbor now and
it's at this stage
when one can have a bit of a wobble
mentally
everything just looks so gray around
here and
looks so cold
we've just seen our first polar bear
that's absolutely magical a
mother-in-such a beautiful sight
and to think that in 30 40 years they
could become extinct
it's a very frightening very very
frightening thought
we're finally at the north pole this is
months and months and months of dreaming
to get here
years of training and planning and
preparation and
in a couple of hours time i'm going to
get in here and do my swim it's all a
little bit frightening but
an emotional
oh
i'm on sun you're ready ready
10 seconds to swim 10 seconds to swim
foreign
so
oh
man
he did it against the current
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you
thank you so much
i'd just like to end off by just saying
this it took me
four months again to feel my hands but
was it worth it yes absolutely it was a
very very few people
who don't know now about what is
happening in the arctic and people ask
me louis what can we do about climate
change
and i say to them i think we need to do
three things
the first thing we need to do is we need
to break this problem down into
manageable chunks
you saw during that video all those
flags
those flags represented the countries
from which my team came from
and equally when it comes to climate
change every single country is going to
have to make cuts
britain america japan south africa the
congo
all of us together we're all on the same
ship together
the second thing we need to do is we
need to just look back
at how far we have come in such a short
period of time
i remember just a few years ago speaking
about climate change
and people heckling me in the back and
saying it doesn't even exist
i've just come back from giving a series
of speeches
in some of the poorest townships in
south africa
to young children as young as 10 years
old
four or five children sitting behind a
desk and even in those poorest
conditions
they all have a very very good grasp
of climate change we need to believe in
ourselves
now's the time to believe we've come a
long way with doing good
but the most important thing we must do
is i think
we must all walk to the end of our lives
and
turn around and ask ourselves the most
fundamental question
and that is what type of world
do we want to live in and what decision
are we going to make today to ensure
that we
all live in a sustainable world
ladies and gentlemen thank you very very
much
at rolex the pursuit of excellence is a
passion
at the heart of every timepiece we make
is the rolex movement
100 conceived by rolex's research and
development teams
every rolex movement undergoes an
exacting production process
one that can take well over a year to
complete
it begins with hundreds of finely
manufactured components
and after careful assembly and minute
adjustments
all that remains is the careful
positioning of the oscillator
this is the heartbeat of every rolex
the moment a rolex truly comes to life
a rolex isn't just a watch
it's technology emboldened by the human
spirit the rolex movement
an entirely swiss-made jewel
the pearl in every oyster that is a
rolex
you